it's been a while  the roads were a little empty  places where we used to gather when  quiet  [Music]  we've gone through a year that tested us  but we're starting to see the promise of  a new day  for more than a hundred years there's  one place  where we all came together to be  entertained  to escape to go someplace new  the movies there's nothing like that  moment when the lights go down  the projector nights  and we believe  tell me you're not thinking what i think  you're thinking there's no bridge  oh hell no  well that was new  after staying apart for so long  you miss the old life do you every day  it's time to come back together  i'm ready if you are  alive my ass is in fuego  we're ready to make you believe again  whoa cause nobody does a comeback  like the movies  it's good to be back  we'll see you soon  [Music]  you